WELCOME THIS EMULATOR IMPLEMENT
COMMITTEE HEARING- DO THE
CONTINUED STATE ON ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISMISSING
HEARING HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDINGS WERE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON ROSS REQUIRED
THE MASTERY WARNING FISCAL
DISSING MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC TESTIFYING
WITH HERE IN THE ROOM OR THE
VIDEO SITE. DO NOT HAVE AMASSED
WHICH PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT YEAH WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT ON. WOMAN TESTIMONY-
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM. BECAME
ONLY. A MINIMAL CONTINUE. OF
STAFF A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PUBLIC IN MEDIA SO THE COMMAND.
SIXTY TO SPACE. IS ALSO. RISK
DISTINCT. THE PUBLIC ENTER IN
THE CAPITAL FOR THOSE HERE AND
THERE ARE. FOR HIM THE PUBLIC
THE ROOM WITH ACCESS. A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND. OF MY
FOR THE PUPPY TIME. WE ASK THAT
THE PA NOT TO. MICHAEL. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONE
YOU'RE DONE TESTS. OR YEARS.
PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
CONTEST. LEAVING THE CAR. WILL
ALSO BE A MORE. WE HAVE ONE WE
HAVE ONE ROOM TEST ONE STATION
PARK. AND WE ALSO BE USED A
MODERATE TELEP SERVICE WHICH
WITNESS TESTIFY A BILL. FOR
CALLING IT A VITAL COMMENT ASK
HE'S STATE- NAME OR- AND PER ON
THE BILL. CALL NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SIX TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE AND THE ACCESS
CODE. IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN AGAIN THE CALL
IN NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY LABOR COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. FOR CALLING IN PLEASE
PLAN TO DO SO IS THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON
IS BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR THE
LINE WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO BE PLACED IN QUEUE
BASED ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
pCALLING IN PLEASE LIMIT ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MEDIA LAST YEAR BROADCAST ON
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE TO
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED THAT YOUR MAIN
WITNESS BY TEST FOR OR AGAINST
A BILL. YOU WILL REMAIN ON THE
LIVE LNE IT WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATOR
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE HAD NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
ONE. OF MY STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO KNOW
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION
LETTER REPORT ON THE COMMITTEES
UP COMMITTEES WEBSITE. WE ALSO
HAVE AN EMAIL ADDRESS SET UP
YOU CAN USE TO EMAIL US YOUR
TESTIMONY. THE EMAIL IS A L. B.
R. DOT COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY DOT
CA DOT GOV CAN THE EMAIL IS A
L. B. R. DOT COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US WE AND-
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL ALSO BE
MINDFULNESS. THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS BE ALL FACE. AT THIS
TIME AS SECRETARY COULD TAKE
ROLLED IN ORDER TO ESTABLISH
CURRENTLY. KALRA THIRD FLOOR.
GONZALEZ. JONES SAWYER RIGHT IS
FAIRLY. WARDS FORMS THANK YOU
SO WE HAVE TO ON CONSENT AS SIX
SEVEN OF HIM AS SEVEN NINE
BAKER ARE AMONG ON THIS BECAUSE
CALENDAR. LET OF SEX PROTECT ST
CONTRA. ON S. B. C. FIFTY
SEVEN. THE MOTION CONSIDERED DO
PASSED CONSENT TO DO COMMITTEE.
ON S. SEVEN ST NINE THE MOTION
IS DUE TO CAN TO APPROACH. WE
HAVE MOTION SIR OKAY. KALRA
THANK KALRA HI FLORA GONZALEZ.
CONSOLE I JONES SAWYER HI JONES
IRATE. REYES ALRIGHT C. R. FORD
FIVE WARD HI. PUBLIC THANK YOU.
S. THE MAJOR FLAW FUTURE. TO
EVER YOU'RE ALREADY HAS SETTLED
INTO THE GAME AND EVERY SB.
SIXTY SIX. MMHM. OKAY THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SB SIXTY TWO MAKES
CLEAR THAT A BUSINESS
CONTRACTING TO HAVE GARMENTS
MADE IS LIABLE FOR UNPAID WAGES
TO THE SKILLED WORKERS WHO MAKE
THE GARMENTS REGARDLESS OF HOW
MANY LAYERSOF CONTRACTING THAT
TWENTY YEARS SINCE THE ORIGINAL
GARMENT WORKER PROTECTION ACT
WAS PASSED WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
TO UNDERLYING CAUSES OF
CONTINUED WAGE THEFT AND IT'S
BECAUSE IT BOB CALIFORNIA TO
FALL BEHIND AND IT'S CAUSED
WORKERS TO RELY N THE GARMENT
RESTITUTION FUND FOR THE WAGES.
THAT MEANS TAXPAYERS ARE ON THE
HOOK TO SUBSIDIZE WHICH LEFT
OFF FIRST FASHION BRANDS CREATE
POVERTY WAGES THROUGH
UNREALISTIC PRICING OF GARMENT
ORDERS YET THEY HAVE NO LEGAL
LIABILITY SECOND IS THE ARCHAIC
SYSTEM OF PAYING BY PIECE RATE
THAT KEEPS MINIMUM WAGE ALWAYS
OUT OF REACH FOR WORKERS
FRANKLY THESE ARE CONDITIONS OF
EUROPEAN IMMIGRANT WOMEN FACED.
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS AGO. I AM
VERY PROUD THAT A HUNDRED AND
FORTY FASHION INDUSTRY
BUSINESSES MOSTLY WOMEN LED
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE LEADING
THE CHARGE FOR ETHICAL
WORKPLACE AND SUSTAINABILITY
STANDARDS IN THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY. THEY ENDORSE THIS
BILL. TO PROTECT HIGHLY SKILLED
GARMENT WORKERS. BECAUSE THE
LOOPHOLES THAT MADE THE
INDUSTRY AND THE LOOPHOLES THAT
MADE THE INDUSTRY HOSTILE TO
ETHICAL GARMENT COMPANIES THAT
ARE TRYING TO ELIMINATE
SWEATSHOPS THEY'RE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT QUOTE UNQUOTE
MADE IN THE USA REPRESENTS
QUALITY AND WORK STANDARDS.
IT'S NOT INTERESTING THAT IN
ADDITION TO ALL THIS
DISRUPTIONS TO THE GLOBAL
SUPPLY CHAIN FROM THE PANDEMIC
HAVE ACTUALLY MOTIVATED
COMPANIES TO SET UP SHOP IN LOS
ANGELES IN THIS STATE. FOR THE
BENEFIT OF SKILLED LABOR
BROWN'S REALIZE THAT THE
ADVANTAGE OF A STRONG DOMESTIC
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY IN
REDUCING RISKS AND COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THERE SHOULD BE
AN AN OVERSIGHT THAT SERVER.
ARE 65% OF RETAILERS HAVE
DECIDED THE ANSWER TO THOSE
RISKS IS ESTABLISHING- FOR
EXPANDING THEIR DOMESTIC
MANUFACTURING. WE'VE HEARD FROM
WOMEN ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO
MADE THE COUNTRY'S MASKS WERE
LITTLE IS TWO CENTS APIECE
WORKING SIXTY HOURS A WEEK
DURING COVERT. SB SIXTY TWO IS
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILL THERE WILL HELP.
REGAIN MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A
WEEK AND WAGES STOLEN FROM
THESE WORKING WOMEN FROM THEIR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY SPEND THEIR MONEY. TODAY
WE HAVE TWO EXPERTS ON- AS
WITNESSES GARMENT WORKER
MAGDELEINE NOT FOOD STORY AS
WELL AS MATTHEW D. CARLESS FROM
BUT SAID IT ON TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU CENTER THE RUSSELL
AND- THE WITNESSES FOR EACH
SIDE HAVE UP TO FOUR MINUTES
AND OF COURSE IF THERE'S AN
INTERPRETER WILL COUNT FOR THAT
AS WELL- WE HAVE MOBILE ENOUGH
TO LEAVE FOLLOWED BY MATTHEW TO
CARELESS. SO MEDINA IF YOU'RE
THERE YOU MAY BEGIN. ARE THERE
SECONDLY. MY NUMBER IT'S MUCH
BETTER NOW THE ONLY THING BUT
THE THING I THOUGHT ABOUT KINDA
LANGUAGE TODAY. SACRAMENTO
SAMIAN BY THE CENTER. OF IT THE
HOBBIT THE LUCK WITH WHATEVER.
DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING IS COME UP
WITH THE HAND MAN OF THE SENT
ONE FOR KIND OF THE- BOTH.
RURAL SOMETIME A COUPLE FROM
WHICH OF. I BELIEVE IS YOUR THE
AMERICAN ALL BUT NOT YOU WILL
WILL COME FEDERAL MY YOUR AND
ALSO THE- SEVEN WITH THAT- WHAT
CHECK MACINNES IN THE SENATE.
ARAMBULA PENDENNIS IT WILL A
HONDA JOSH WITHIN THE MCCARTY
AND HE'S BACK WITH THE BAND. I
THANK BY YOUR MOTHER. BUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEAH. DOESN'T
SOUND IDEAL FROM NEW YORK. BUT
MR PROBLEM BACKGROUND THAT ARE
MY PARENTS LET MEANING. AMOUNT
OF YOUR- IN THE LONG. MIDDLE
EAST YOU HAVE MEANT BUT I HOPE
WHAT AND SO. AT THE END OF. BUT
I'M NOT. THANK. ONE BUT INSTEAD
OF ASPHALT. BUT I CAN'T
REMEMBER THE I LOVE YOU BATTERY
YOU KNOW TIME NOT A DO YOU.
SOMEONE SAID ME THAT I WILL
THAT. KAMALA PRIVATE THE FLA
BACK BACK THEN THAT WOULD
AFFECT THE GROUND BREAKING THE
VIEW THAT THE LOOK IN
CALIFORNIA YEAH. HI EVERYONE
THIS IS DAISY GONZALEZ WITH A
GARMENT WORKER CENTER- I AM
JUST GOING TO BE TRANSLATING BY
THE END OF TESTIMONY NO
PROBLEM. SHE SAID THAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY
NAME IS MULLIN NOW WITH THE
WINGS I HAVE BEEN WORKING
FOURTEEN YEARS IN THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY. I'M A MEMBER OF THE
GARMENT WORKER CENTER IN MY
FOURTEEN YEARS OF THE GARMENT
WORKER I'VE BEEN PAID CENTS FOR
EACH PIECE A CELL BERMAN
WORKERS ARE SKILLED WORKERS I
OPERATE THE OVERLOCK MACHINE
AND SINGLE NEEDLE MACHINE BUT
THE MAJORITY OF US KNOW HOW TO
USE. ANY DIFFERENT INDUSTRIAL
MACHINE. THREE A PANDEMIC
CONTINUE WORKING. MANY OF US
MASS THAT HOSPITAL GOWNS THEY
EVEN DESIGNATED AS ESSENTIAL
WORKERS BUT THE SALARIES DIDN'T
CHANGE FOR MY ORK. I AM NOT
PAID THE MINIMUM WAGE FOR A
WEEK OF WORK AND MAKE THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FROM MONDAY TO
FRIDAY FOR A FULL WEEK OF WORK.
ABOUT THE FIND A SECOND JOB TO
SUPPORT MY TWO SONS. I PRODUCED
FOR MULTI MILLION DOLLAR
COMPANIES LIKE FOREVER TWENTY
ONE BYE BYE YEAH AND ALITY.
INDEED RENDON MILLION DOLLAR
COMPANY BECAUSE THEY CREATE
CONTRACTS. KNOWING THAT THE
WORKERS WILL ONLY BE PAID A
MERE CENTS FOR THEIR WORK. FOR
THIS POINTS THAT THE END AND
FOR US TO BE PAID A MINIMUM
WAGE WE NEED TO ELIMINATE THE
P. THREE AND CREATE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE BRANCH
FOR THE WAGE THAT BECAUSE- WE
ASK YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS TO
SUPPORT US AND PASSED SB SIXTY
TWO. AT THIS LOT SB SIXTY TWO
WAS PASSED. I'LL BE ABLE TO
SPEND MORE TIME WITH MY
CHILDREN AND NOT HAVE TO TAKE
THEM TO THE FACTORY WITH ME. AT
THIS LAW PASSES IT WOULD HAVE A
MAJOR EFFECT ON THE LIVES. OF
GARMENT WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MATTHEW TO CARELESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN HONORABLE MEMBERS
THAT'S I THINK IS THE NONPROFIT
LEGAL AID ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
REPRESENTED HUNDREDS OF GARMENT
WORKERS OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS I'M THE STAFF ATTORNEY
THAT CELTIC AND WE ARE PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR SB SIXTY TWO. IN OUR
WORK WE HAVE SEEN OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WHAT NEEDS TO WE DESCRIBE
SO POWERFULLY. AND THAT SENATOR
ROSCOE REFERENCED AT THE GOAL
BUSINESSES HAVE SEEN IT TOO
WHICH IS WHY MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND FORTY GARMENT
INDUSTRY BUSINESSES SUPPORT
THIS BILL TO PROTECT WORKERS.
ELIMINATE SWEATSHOPS AND LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD. ACADEMIC
RESEARCH AND GOVERNMENT
INVESTIGATIONS MAKE CLEAR ABUSE
THE PIECE RATES ON THE ROOT
CAUSES OF THE WIDESPREAD WAGE
THEFT THAT PLAGUED THE INDUSTRY
IN OUR STATE. THE PIECE RATE
DESCRIBES HOW LOW THE PAY ISN'T
MAKES IMPORTS IT MORE DIFFICULT
BY COMPLICATING WAGE
CALCULATIONS. THE P. THREE ALSO
CAUSES HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROBLEMS BECAUSE WORKERS MUST
RACE TO COMPLETE AS MANY ITEMS
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. AND
THEY DO NOT GET PAID PER TIME
THE SANITIZER WORKSTATIONS OR
WASH THEIR HANDS. WHICH CREATES
A PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT FOR
THESE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
ESPECIALLY NOW. BY ELIMINATING
THE PIECE RATE- SB SIXTY TWO
STILL ALLOWS FOR BONUS AND
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS. TO ENSURE
THAT WORKERS ARE PAID FAIRLY.
AS MIZZOU TO WE HAS REFERENCED
THE UP CHAIN COMPANIES HAVE
USED SUBCONTRACTING HOW THEIR
CLOTHING MADE IN THE SOME AWFUL
CONDITIONS AND CURRENTLY THEY
ARE NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE. THE
BRANDS ARE INCENTIVIZED TO
CONTRACT WITH THE LOWEST BIDDER
MANY OF THEM ARE ONLY ABLE TO
BID SO LOW BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
PAYING THEIR WORKERS MINIMUM
WAGE. BY HOLDING BRANDS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE ROLE THEY
PLAY IN PRODUCTION CHAIN WE
WILL INCENTIVIZE THEM TO PAY
FOR GOODS AT PRICES
COMMENSURATE WITH WORKERS
EARNING THE MINIMUM WAGE. AND
BEYOND. AND THE LIMITING THE
PATRIOT SYSTEM WILL PREVENT
MANUFACTURE SOMETHING THE PIECE
RATE SO LOW THAT IT'S
ESSENTIALLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR
WORKERS. TO MAKE THE MINIMUM
WAGE. THE BILL ALSO EMPOWER THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S ZERO FIELD
ENFORCEMENT. TO SITE OPTION
COMPANIES IN WORKPLACE WIDE
COMMON INVESTIGATIONS THIS IS A
POWER THEY CURRENTLY LACK. OF
WHICH ALSO CONTRIBUTES TO THE
LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY. THE
TIME HAS COME TO FULLY REALIZE
THE INTENT OF THE ORIGINAL
GARMENTS BILL AB SIX THIRTY
THREE FROM NINETEEN NINETY NINE
TO CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE FOR THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY HAS EVOLVED TO
EXPLOIT. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOW WE
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT WE ASK
THAT YOU JUST STATE YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. OF THE START WAS IN THE
ROOM. ANYONE SUPPORT- ONE THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. AND
THEN MOVE ON NOW TO- MODERATOR
IF YOU HAVE ANYONE IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN IN
Q. WHAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MONICA DEMERIT PM BEHALF OF
EQUAL SORRY MONICA MERRITT CAN
BE HAVE THE STRONG CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU BRING FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARICA
GUESSING ARE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND TALK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JESSICA STAND
ON BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP
BROUGHT ON BEHALF THE TEAMSTERS
AND UNITED HERE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FIVE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON TERRY MEMBERS DADDY
GREAT WELL LET'S SEE IF HE W.
WESTERN STATE COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANKS
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
BURKE CHRISTOPHER SPONSORS
POLICY ADVOCATE WORKING
FAMILIES PARTY THE PART OF THE
A CO SPONSOR AND ALSO COMMENDED
FOR OUR FRIEND THAT WHAT'S THE
PRODUCT YOU DON'T SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FRANK TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE MEMBER KATHY VAN
OSTERN REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I AM THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GLOBAL SHEA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION A
PROUD COACH BONSER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FIND FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. RELATED
BY ORDER WITH THE FBI YOU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. RIGHT EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR TURN MEMBERS CHECKED IN ROWS
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIND TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SEPTIMUS RICHARD MEMBERS
ALEXANDER OUT YOU GET IT YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BY TWENTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AS OUR MILLER
WALLFISCH FOR LEGAL AID AT WORK
IN SUPPORT. ONE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
STARTING IN BURKE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIXTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BRIAN SCHATZ PLEASE
GO AHEAD. UNDERWATER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU FOR NOW WE CAN MOVE ON
OPPOSITION TO TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE- ASHLEY
HOFFMAN THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. AS SOON AS YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS ACTUALLY HW
OFTEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FIFTY TWO IS A JOB KILLER.
INSTEAD OF GOING AFTER GARMENT
MANUFACTURERS ARE BRANDS THAT
ARE VIOLATING THE LAW THE BILL
SETS A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT
REGARDING JOINT LIABILITY AND
ALLOW THOSE COMPANIES TO
CONTINUE TO ACT UNLAWFULLY BY
PASSING THE LIABILITY FOR WAGE
CLAIMS THE COMPANIES THAT HAVE
NO CONTROL OVER THE GARMENT
WORKERS THEIR WAGES OR WORKING
CONDITIONS. AND DID NOT CHOOSE
THE CONTRACT WITH A COMPANY
THAT VIOLATING THE LAW IT DOES
THIS BY ESTABLISHING A NEW
CATEGORY OF COMPANIES THAT ARE
LIABLE FOR ALL OF THE GARMENT
WORKERS WAGE CLAIMS CULT BRAND
GUARANTORS. BRING YOUR IN
TORRANCE BROADLY DEFINED AND
INCLUDES ANY COMPANY THAT HAS
INVOLVEMENT WHATSOEVER WITH
LICENSING MAKING UP GARMENTS
DYING AFFIXING A LABEL TO
GARMENTS OR OTHERWISE ALTERING
GARMENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
PROPONENTS OF THE BILLS SEEK TO
PUNISH BAD BRAND TO DO NOT TAKE
CONTRACTORS ENOUGH MONEY FOR
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS FIRST
ACTUALLY ALREADY ILLEGAL UNDER
LABOR CODE SECTION TWENTY EIGHT
TEN UNDER THAT LABOR CODE
SECTION IT'S ILLEGAL TO ENTER
INTO A CONTRACT WHERE YOU KNOW
OR SHOULD KNOW. THAT THE
CONTRACT IS INSUFFICIENT TO PAY
WORKERS FOR THE MANUFACTURING.
WORKER CAN ALREADY FEEL UNDER
THAT LABOR CODE FOR DAMAGES.
AND PENALTIES AND A TREE.
SECOND THE ENDED CONSEQUENCES
THE BREXIT THIS BILL IS THAT
COULD GRANDPA END UP PAY FOR
THAT. OF BREATH BECAUSE THERE
ARE NO LIMITS. ON MY- BRING
YOUR TOWARDS ARE LIABLE FOR
EMPLOYEES AND HIGHER WAGE QUITE
NOT MERELY FOR WAGES. FOR TIME
SPENT ON GOVERNMENT. ISSUED ID
WITH THE ENTITY. IF YOU HAD AN
ENTERTAINMENT COMPANY THAT
LICENSE OUT A LOGO. AND A
LICENSOR THAT THEY USE
CONTRACTS THAT PATRICK STATE
WITH THAT LOGO. IF THEY CONTACT
ME FACTURE. THE CONTRACT OF THE
THIRD QUARTER AND PAY THAT FOR
A HIGH PRICE. BUT I'VE BEEN
INCIDENT THAT SEWER
SUBSEQUENTLY TAKE LOW PAYING
CONTRACT FROM THE FAST FASHION
BRANDS AND FAILS TO PAY MINIMUM
WAGE. CENTER CAME AND COMPANY
THAT NARROWING THE LICENSOR IS
NOW LIABLE FOR ALL OF THE
WORKERS CLAIM. THE BILL
ELIMINATES THE APPORTIONMENT OF
LIABILITY THAT PRESENTLY EXISTS
IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY WILL
BEGIN NEGOTIATING POINT IN
EIGHTY SIX THIRTY THREE. THIS
IS AN UNPRECEDENTED EXPANSION
OF GOING LIABILITIES THAT DOES
NOT SURE WE'RE ACTUALLY HOLDING
LIABLE BECAUSE THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FAILURE TO
ADEQUATELY PAID WORKERS. IN
FACT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
ADDRESS THE NEED FOR MORE
TARGETED ENFORCEMENT ARM
INDUSTRY AND ELIMINATE THESE
BAD ACTORS WHO OFTEN DO NOT
REGISTER. B. THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HERSELF DURING THE
BUDGET PROVIDE HEARING THIS
YEAR STATED THE WAY THAT TO
SOLVE THESE ISSUES SURROUNDING
THE ABILITY TO PAY GOVERNMENT
WORKER CLAIMS. IF THE INCREASE
ENFORCEMENT SO VACANCIES AND
EDUCATE WORKERS. DRIVING GOOD
BRANDS OUT OF CALIFORNIA IS NOT
THE ANSWER. FOR THESE REASONS
AND MORE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB
SIX DETAIL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. BUT WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT- FOR ANYONE OPPOSED TO.
ANYONE IN THE ROOM. AND AGAIN A.
STATE NAME AFFILIATION POSITION
ON THE BILL. OUR NOW IN THE
ROOM MOVE ON. MANSLAUGHTER TO
ANY IN OP. ON THE PHONE. TO ASK
SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK CANNOT. TO ASK
BASIC TWO PLEASE ONE THE ZERO
AFTER TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT SRI IN Q. WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS RYAN ELAINE
WOULD BE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE TWO
MORE IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THE NEXT COMMENT
WHICH. OUR NEXT COMMENTS FROM
LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NUMBER EACH TEAM WILL
HELP WITH THE SUBJECT
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS LORD TODAY NO WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S GO AND BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION. ON THE TABLE FROM A
SUMMER GONZALEZ SECOND BY
SURVEYORS. AND IT YES SUMMER
AWARD. THANK U. S. SENATE DR
RICE WANTED KNOWLEDGE OF REALLY
APPRECIATE I KNOW YOU HAD A LOT
LONG TIME HOW LONG HISTORY
WORKING FOR THOSE- IN THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY IN PARTICULAR
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE I THINK
THAT WORKERS ESPECIALLY.
APPRECIATED AND COMMENDED- AS I
KNOW YOU REITERATED- WE'VE GOT
A LOT OF ENDEMIC ISSUES WITH
EMPLOYMENT VIOLATIONS SPECIFIC
TO THIS INDUSTRY AND I KNOW
THAT- THE BILL CONTINUES SOME
OF THE WORK THAT WAS ENACTED
FROM NINETEEN NINETY NINE- I
KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO SEEK TO
REDUCE THE AND INFRACTIONS THAT
ARE AVOIDING LIABILITY- THAT
ARE KEEN TO EXPLOIT WORKERS-
INDUCED WAGE THEFT- AND- FOR
THOSE THAT ARE UNABLE TO. HELP
OTHERS ARE UNABLE TO RECOVER
SOME OF THEIR STOLEN WAGES- SO
THANK YOU VERY REACHING SING
THIS BILL I THINK IT'S GOING A
LONG WAY TO HELP. THOSE THAT
OFTEN DON'T HAVE A VOICE I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE A VOICE FOR SO MANY
UP HERE. AND I'M I'M REALLY
HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR. OFF HI MY-
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT BACK
I AM PROUD TO BE A JOIN AUTHOR
WITH YOU ON THIS IS. US SO
COMPELLING. AND THE OPPOSITION
THAT WOULD SUGGEST SOMEHOW THIS
IS TOO HARD FOR. COMPANIES TO-
FIGURE OUT WHAT. THE COMPANIES
ARE BUYING FROM WHETHER OR NOT.
THEY'RE PAYING THEIR WORKERS I
REMIND PEOPLE THAT AT LEAST. I
KNOW WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE IT
WAS A BIG DEAL THAT THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY TRACE. BACK THE
CLOTHING THAT WAS BOUGHT IN
FOREIGN COUNTRIES. TO SUGGEST
THAT THAT WASN'T BEING
PURCHASED FROM SWEAT SHOP SO- I
I'M SURE WE CAN FIGURE OUT A
WAY IN THE UNITED STATES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA FOR. FOR THE
RETAILERS TO. FIND OUT THE
CONDITIONS UNDERWHICH- THOSE
IN THIS COUNTRY ARE ARE NOT
BEING PAID OR ARE BEING PAID
FOR THEIR LABOR. THANK YOU
SOMERS ON SOLAR. I ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE AS A PROP
COAUTHOR AND ALSO- WHEN WE WHEN
WE COME HERE WE THINK OF THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO. THAT WILL HELP
EVERYONE WE ALL ARE ASKED WOULD
YOU COME TO SACRAMENTO TO DO.
THIS LAWS WHY I'M HERE MY
MOTHER WORKED IN THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY FOR TWO DECADES. SHE
WORKED AT HOOVER IN WASHINGTON
JODY TO TAKE. DATE UP AND- MY
MOTHER IS EIGHTY FOUR YEARS OLD
HAS A MYRIAD OF MEDICAL
PROBLEMS THEY LEFT WITH NO
RETIREMENT. NO MEDICAL IN A
SMALL SEVERANCE PAY. AND I
REMEMBER VISITING MY MOTHER.
ALL THE YEARS OF MY LIFE EVEN
IN COLLEGE- I REMEMBER WHEN THE
WORKERS MOSTLY LATINOS. THEY
GOT A SWAP AND- EMIR A BUT IT
DIED AND GONE HAVE. BECAUSE THE
SWELTERING HEAT IN A PLACE WAS
SO BAD. I REMEMBER THE LONG
HOURS THE LAW THE LOW PAY. SO I
HAVE SEEN THE IMPACTS OF THESE
INJUSTICES AND EXPLOITIVE
PRACTICES HAPPEN GARMENT
WORKERS AT THE HANDS OF THIS
INDUSTRY. I CITIES WRONGDOINGS
HAPPENING MY DISTRICT OF SOUTH
LA WHERE HUNDREDS OF WORKERS
PRIMARILY IMMIGRANT WOMEN. OUR
SPENDING COUNTLESS HOURS MAKING
CLOTHING OR PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT ONLY TO BE PAID CENTS
FOR EVERY PIECE OF EQUIPMENT AS
LITTLE AS FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR.
THESE COMPANIES SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO USE LOOPHOLES IN
STATE LAW TO MAKE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN PROFITS AND NOT PAY
THEIR WORKERS WITH THEIR BOAT.
MY MOTHER A LOT OF WAYS. WAS TO
GO BETWEEN IN SOME WAYS SHE WAS
A UNION LEADER. TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE GO TO
WEDDINGS. TO BE WITH THEIR
FAMILY. AND THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER NEVER REALLY
CAMERA. AND SO THIS LAW
STRENGTH INTO TO ENSURE THAT WE
DO OUR JOBS IN THE GOVERNMENT.
AS FAR AS THE GARMENT- I
REMEMBER I WENT TO USC AND I
WOULD SEE THESE CLOTHING THE
SAME CLOTHING THAT MY MOTHER
MADE FROM SHANKLAND AT THESE
IMMIGRANT WOMEN MADE BY AT THE
FRATERNITY HOUSES AT USC ALL
ROUND CAPTAIN SYSTEM PARTIES
AND THEY WOULD GO TO I MAGNUM'S
PROBABLY WOULD ONLY TO THE
NETWORK BULLOCKS AND BY MAGNUM-
AT THAT TIME WITH THE NEWMARKET
OF. OF THE TIME THEY WERE SPENT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS FOR
DRESSES. THAT MY MOTHER MADE.
TENCENT'S FINTECH FIVE CENTS ON
THE DOLLAR. AND WHEN THEY
COULDN'T SELL THEM THEY WOULD
HAVE A PARKING LOT. AND I WOULD
TELL THE AFTER AMERICAN LATINOS
THAT MATIBA CD COME TO PARKING
LOTS OF THE SAME TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLAR DRESSES THEY COULD
GET FOR TEN DOLLARS. FIFTEEN
DOLLARS. SO PERSONALLY I'VE
NEVER BOUGHT ANYTHING. AT COST.
BECAUSE I KNOW THE COST OF WHAT
IT TAKES. BUT I ALSO KNOW HOUSE
OVERPRICED AND HOW. THESE
BRANDS ARE MAKING MONEY. OFF
THE SWEAT OF PEOPLE. ON SHE
HUGE RETAIL AND PROFITS AND SO-
I WANT TO THANK YOU BECAUSE- I
GET TO SHOW MY MOTHER WHY SHE
RAISED ME. I GET TO SHOW MY
MOTHER WHY I'M HERE. THAT I GET
TO PROVE TO HER THAT SHE DID
THE RIGHT THING SHE RAISED ME.
AND THAT THIS IS A RIGHTEOUS
BILL AND WE SHOULD MOVE FORWARD
WITH IT CHAU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SUMMARY JONES SAWYER- AND
THAT THE POWERFUL CONNECTION
AND THIS IS A MULTI
GENERATIONAL FIGHT. THAT IN-
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT. CRITICISM
OF THE JOINT LIABILITY WITH A
LOOK AT THE END OF THE DAY
THESE COMPANIES KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING THEY'RE PROFITING
WILDLY FROM WHAT THEY HAVE FOR
DECADES- AND THEY CAN'T STICK
THEIR HEAD IN THE SAND AND
CONTINUE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
THESE WORKERS- AND- I
APPRECIATE YOUR- PERSISTENCE.
AND ON THIS PIECE LEGISLATION-
YOU KNOW WE ARE WE ARE SEEING
SECOND THIRD FOURTH GENERATION
WORKERS- YOU KNOW THAT THAT IS
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN- IT'S- AND
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF- YOU KNOW
OVER MANY DECADES. BUT WITH
YOUR LEADERSHIP- CENTER THAT
ALSO AND I'M VERY PROUD TO BE A
PRINCIPAL AUTHOR AND I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD FROM. OTHER
COLLEAGUES HERE WE'RE ALL WITH
YOU TO MAKE SURE THIS LAST
GENERATION. THE SUFFERS THIS
KIND OF INJUSTICE. AND SO WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY
CLOSING. COMMENTS I APPRECIATE
ALL OF YOUR HEARTFELT- REMARKS
IN SUPPORT- URGE AND I VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
AMOUNTS ATTRIBUTABLE CALL ON SB
SIXTY TWO PLEASE. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
KALRA BY THE KALRA FLOOR.
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ SIDE JONES
SAWYER FOR MY MOTHER BY JUNE
MILLER I'D RADIUS SIERRA. WARD
BY WARD I. RIGHT THE BILL'S OUT
COLLEGES THANK YOU CENTER THANK
YOU MEMBERS. I REMEMBER TO THIS
BEFORE TEN SANDRA LEYVA. SO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIZEABLE.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
SENATE BILL FOR TEN INSURERS
THAT WORKER SAFETY IS NEVER
DELAYED OR SATISFIED AS A
RESULT OF DUPLICATIVE EXPENSIVE
AND UNNECESSARY ANALYSIS IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THEN GOVERNOR
BROWN SIGNED INTO LAW SB SIX
SEVENTEEN WHICH REQUIRE STATE
AGENCIES TO PREPARE AN IN DEPTH
ECONOMIC ASSESSMENT OF ANY
REGULATION WITH AN ESTIMATED
FISH FINANCIAL IMPACT OF OVER
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. THIS
ECONOMIC ASSESSMENT IS CALLED
THE STANDARDIZED REGULATORY
IMPACT ASSESSMENT ALSO KNOWN AS
THE SHARIA WHEN IT COMES TO
WORKER SAFETY AND HEALTH
REFORMS WERE ALREADY AWARE OF
THE EXTENSIVE PROCESS THAT
EXIST BEFORE A RULE CAN BE
FINALIZED THOSE STEPS INCLUDE.
A BILL SIGNED INTO LAW
DIRECTING THE CALIFORNIA
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS FOR TO TAKE ACTION ON
A PARTICULAR ISSUE TO MULTIPLE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE MEETINGS
THREE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE
ACT WITH WHICH WILL FURTHER
ASSESS THE FISCAL IMPACT FOR
THE O. S. H. S. B. THAT
EXTENSIVELY REVIEWS THE COSTS
AND BENEFITS OF ANY STANDARD BY
THIS POINT AT LEAST FOR
THOROUGH FISCAL ANALYSIS WILL
HAVE OCCURRED FOR THE RULE
MAKING PROCESS TO BE COMPLETED.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THE THREE
OF REVIEW MANDATES A FIFTH
FISCAL ANALYSIS IN THE MIDDLE
OF THIS ALREADY VERY THOROUGH
PROCESS THE THREE I CAN EXTEND
THE RULE MAKING PROCESS BY ONE
TO TWO YEARS OR MORE AND IN
TURN CONTINUED CONTINUE TO
ENDANGER THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS IN THE WORKPLACE A
FURTHER DELAY IN ADOPTING
SAFETY STANDARDS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN RECOMMENDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR AND
ALREADY GONE THROUGH MULTIPLE
LEVELS OF ADMINISTRATIVE FISCAL
REVIEW MAY PLACE WORKERS AT AN
INCREASED RISK OF INJURY OR
DEATH. PROPOSAL STUDENTS THAT
DO NOT REQUIRE THE STREET SUCH
AS INDOOR HEAT STANDARD
PROPOSED REQUIRED BY SB ELEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN WHICH WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN HAS SUFFERED SEVERE
DELAYS AS A RESULT OF THIS
PROCESS FIVE YEARS TO BE EXACT.
THE LANGUAGE FOR INDOOR HEAT
STANDARD HAS YET TO EVEN DEEPER.
TO THE O. S. H. S. B. DESPITE
LET'S LEGISLATION REQUIRING
THAT THIS HAPPENED MORE THAN
TWO YEARS AGO. THIS IS TO
ADDITIONAL YEARS THUS FAR THE
INDOOR WORKERS HAVE LABORED IN
GRUELING HEAT WITH NO CLEAR HE
PROTECTION UNDER THE LAW. WELL
THE PANDEMIC IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
SOME OF THE DELAY THEY ARE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF IT. ALSO
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS TO
SIGNIFICANT EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS WERE APPROVED IN
SIX TO SEVEN MONTHS ONE
PROTECTING WORKERS FROM
WILDFIRE SMOKE AND ANOTHER FROM
COVERED NINETEEN. AS EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS THESE DID NOT
REQUIRE THE SHARIA BUT THE
REGULATION STILL RECEIVED A
THOROUGH VETTING WITH PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AGENCY
ANALYSIS AND STAKEHOLDER PHILIP
FEEDBACK. THESE AND OTHER
EXPERIENCES HAVE CONFIRMED THAT
SHRIYA BRINGS LITTLE TO THE
WORKER SAFETY RULE MAKING
PROCESS. OTHER THAN GREATER
DELAYS AS SUCH AS BEFORE TEN
EXEMPTS WORKER SAFETY RULE
MAKING FROM THE REQUIREMENT TO
PERFORM S. RIA I'M PROPOSED
MAJOR ROLE MAKING. THIS EXAMPLE
REGULATIONS THIS EXEMPTION
ALREADY EXISTS FOR SEVERAL
AGENCIES CONSIDER INCLUDING THE
FEC AND UC HASTINGS. ALL OTHER
EXISTING LAYERS OF REVIEW
INCLUDING INTERNAL FOR FISCAL
ANALYSIS THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
PROCESS THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH STANDARDS BOARD'S
PUBLIC HEARINGS AND MEETINGS.
AND THE STANDARD OF RULE MAKING
PROCESS REMAIN IN PLACE THIS
BILL REFLECTS THE EXCEPTIONALLY
DETAILED FISCAL ANALYSIS.
ALREADY CURSED AT CAL OSHA AND
ALLOWS THE AGENCY TO FOCUS
SCARCE RESOURCES AND MORE
EFFECTIVE WAYS MOST IMPORTANTLY
THIS BILL WILL HELP PROTECT
WORKERS SAFETY AND HEALTH
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT IS MITCH
STEIGER. OF THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. THE YOU SIR
LEYVA- MY STAGGER WHENEVER
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL. WE
BELIEVE THAT AT HEART IT'S
REALLY ABOUT MAKING GOVERNMENT
WORK BETTER ALLOWING THIS ONE
PROCESS TO WORK FASTER AT LESS
COST WHILE IN THE WITH LIMITING
THE ABILITY OF STAKEHOLDERS TO
WEIGH IN ON THE PROCESS. AND
SINCE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WORKERS SAFETY ALLOWING THE
STANDARDS TO GET IN PLACE
FASTER MEANS PREVENTING
INJURIES AND ILLNESSES AND
SAVING LIVES SUTTER LEYVA
REFERENCE EXAMPLE OF THE INDOOR
HEAT WHICH IS REALLY A PERFECT.
ONE TO GET A WHY THIS BILL IS
SO IMPORTANT. OFFICE OF SETTING
UP THE CENTER HAS INVOLVED
MULTIPLE ADVISORY COMMITTEES
AND SO THESE ARE. VERY LARGE
OPEN TO THE PUBLIC OPEN THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHOEVER WANTS TO
SHOW UP AND CALM AND THERE NO
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY PEOPLE CAN
SPEAK FOR. AS LONG AS THEY WANT
GET INTO AS MUCH DETAIL AS THEY
LIKE ON. ANY OF THE TOPICS
RELATED TO THE ISSUE IN HERE
THE ECONOMIC DETAILS WERE VERY
RELEVANT NEVER BROUGHT UP OVER
AND OVER AGAIN WE GOT INTO
GREAT DETAIL ABOUT WHAT
EMPLOYERS BELIEVED TO BE AT THE
COST OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE-
AND SO WE HAD THESE ALL OVER
THE STATE. AND THEN AFTER ALL
THOSE HAD CONCLUDED THERE WERE
EIGHT DIFFERENT VERSIONS OF
LANGUAGE THAT WERE PRESENTED
WITH WEEKS TO COMMENTS ON EACH
ONE. AND THE LANGUAGE OF
EVENTUALLY COMPLETED IN APRIL
OF TWENTY NINETEEN. AND AS WAS
MENTIONED IT WAS OVER TWO YEARS
AGO AND SENSE WORKERS HAVE JUST
BEEN. SITTING AND WAITING AND
SUFFERING THROUGH THIS HAZARD
WITHOUT A STANDARD BUT THE
PROBLEM HAS CONTINUED. WE
LOOKED INTO THE RECORDS AND
FOUND THAT SINCE JANUARY FIRST
OF TWENTY NINETEEN THERE HAVE
BEEN AT LEAST SIXTY DIFFERENT
INDOOR HEAT SPECIFIC COMPLAINTS
FILED WITH QALISYA. EVEN
WITHOUT A STANDARD TO ENFORCE
BUT WORKERS THOUGHT THE PROBLEM
WAS STILL SO BAD. THEY STILL
CALL CALIFORNIA TO SEE WHAT
COULD B DONE AND THE PROBLEM
IS JUST GOING TO KEEP
CONTINUING UNTIL WE DO
SOMETHING. AND WILL SOON
BECAUSE THAT WE'RE NOT SAYING
THAT SERIOUS ARE USELESS WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO WEIGH IN ON THEIR
VALUE FOR OTHER AGENCIES WE AT
LEAST IN THE CASE OF WORKER
SAFETY. THEY ARE INTERESTING
AND THEY ARE HELPFUL BUT-
WHATEVER THEIR VALUE IS WE
BELIEVE IT'S IMMEASURABLY LESS
THAN THE VALUE OF A WORKER'S
LIFE. AND THAT'S REALLY THE
DECISION THAT WE'RE MAKING HERE
BY ALLOWING THE SYSTEM TO
CONTINUE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO
DEAL WITH THIS DELAY OF ONE TO
TWO YEARS LETTING WORKERS GET
HURT. LETTING SOME WORKERS DIED
DEPENDING ON THE HAZARD WHILE
WE WAIT THIS DOCUMENT TO BE
WAIT FOR THE DOCUMENT TO BE
COMPLETED. AND WHATEVER THE
VALUE IS IT'SJUST NOT AS MUCH
AS KEEPING WORKERS ALIVE. WE DO
THINK THERE IS PRECEDENT GIVEN
THAT OTHER AGENCY PROCESSES ARE
EXEMPT FROM THIS REQUIREMENT I
THINK IT MAKES A WHOLE LOT OF
SENSE HERE AND WE STRONGLY URGE.
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR. IN
A TOUGH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALTHOUGH NOTHING PUBLICLY- YES
STATE NAME AFFILIATE POSITION
THE BILL. AND IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM. IF NOT- MODERATOR
WE HAVE ANYONE IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE FOR S. B. FOR TEN.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FOR TEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT FIVE IN Q. WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE START
OF THE GRANT WHILE WITH THE F.
T. W. WESTERN STATES
COMPLIMENTS ON THE PART THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU BYE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WE'RE NAY BY OUR WITH AT THE
ARE YOU CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NINE FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CAREY MEMBERS MATT
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GET
AFTERNOON THIS CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS TRAVIS YOUR CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT
LEFT BEFORE CLASS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BYE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MODERATOR MISTER CHAIRMAN OR
THE COMMITTEE GERMANS THAT
EUROPEAN BUT THE STATE WILL BE
A CONSTRUCTION TRADE COUNCIL
ALSO SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU I'LL MOVE ON OPPOSITION TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
ARE MUTUALLY BY PHONE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
ROBERT MUCH MAKEUP WE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE OPPOSE I
RESPECTFULLY TO THE POOR CAN.
I'D LIKE TO VERIFY AND ENSURE
FOCUS HERE. NOW THIS IS
TRANSPARENCY MEASURES ALWAYS
TAKE TIME RIGHT THE COMMITTEES
THAT ALICE'S ATTRACTED BY STAFF
THAT CAN MEET HEARING ALL THOSE
STEPS TAKE TIME WE BELIEVE THAT
QUALITY ANALYSIS ACCURACY
IMPORTANT ENOUGH THAT WE
PURSUED POLITICS. ANOTHER THING
THE QUESTION BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE REGARDING US REPORT
TEN. TO BRIEFLY TOUCH ON THE
INDOOR HE P. WE CERTAINLY AGREE
THAT THE INDOOR HEAT SENATE
RELATIONS MOVED QUICKER BUT TO
THROW OUT A VALUABLE PROCESS
BECAUSE WE HAVE FOUND AN
EXAMPLE WE THINK IT'S NOT THE
RIGHT CHOICE HERE- TO GET
BACKGROUND AS THE SENATOR NOTED
THIS- ST PROCESS JANITORIAL
TRAINING PACKET THAT. MEANT HE
NOW THAT WAS PUT IN PLACE BY
THE LEGISLATION BY- CALDERON IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I HEARD A
THRESHOLD THE HIGH THRESHOLD OF
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IT'S
TRIGGERED VERY FEW REGULATION.
OF THE WHOLE STATE EVERY
DONATION PASSED REPUGNANT.
ABOUT TEN REGULATIONS THE YEAR-
CALL. TO WHAT THE OF. I AYE WE
SAY THAT THE CONTENTS THE THREE
OUT THAT ARE NOT DUPLICATE IT
AND THERE NOT CAP OTHER NOW. TO
THE CONTRARY TO RENT HOUSES IN
THOROUGH. AND CAN MUCH MORE
HELPFUL INFORMATION FOR THE
POLICY MAKERS TO VOTE ON THESE
REGULATIONS. AS WELL AS FOR THE
COMMUNITY. ONE EXAMPLE- ONE
PIECE THAT I CANNOT DOUBT THAT
THAT WOULD REMAIN WOULD BE D.
I. AFTER ECONOMIC IMPACT
STATEMENT- THIS IS A FIVE PAGE
FILL IN THE BLANK FORM. THAT I
HAVE TO BE SUBMITTED ALONG WITH
REGULATIONS. IN CONTRAST SHARIA
WE'RE LOOKING AT SOMETHING MORE
LIKE. SIXTY TO EIGHTY PAGES. OF
THAT KIND OF AN OUT THAT YOU
WOULD KEEP A PUBLIC POLICY
GRADUATE PROGRAM- WITH THE FACT
HOW MUCH HOW MANY YEARS WILL IT
AFFECT THEM. WELL THE COST OF
COMPLIANCE GO DOWN IS IT A ONE
YEAR PROBLEM OR GET THE
ACCELERATING COSTS WERE IN
TWENTY YEARS THE COST BLESSED
TO BE ON THE TENABLE. THOSE ARE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE CONTAINED
ELSEWHERE- CHU AND I'D LIKE THE
FLAG ONE POINT IT WAS NOT
MENTIONED THIS COMMITTED NOW.
BUT WHAT MENTIONED IN THE
SENATE COMMITTEE NOW THAT.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OVERSEAS.
AND CHECK STEPS TO HEY LISTEN
YOU'VE GOT MISCALCULATIONS RAW
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THIS WRONG.
PLEASE TRESPASS. THAT'S NOT
CONTAINED OTHER PLACES YOU'RE
LOSING A PIECE THAT. OVERSIGHT
THERE- AND DECLINE THAT IT
CONTAINED ELSEWHERE I THINK IT
IS REALLY. INACCURATE TO MY
KNOWLEDGE OF THOSE PROFITS- AS
YOU AGE YOU CAN BUT ON. STOP
ALL THE IT CAN. WITHOUT THAT
DOES. BUT I THINK IT'S A BACK
TO THE QUESTION. IS DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT THAT KIND OF
QUALITY KNOWLEDGE IT IS WORTH
HAVING- I'D LIKE TO FIVE ONE
THE OTHER SPECIFIC THAT THERE
WAS A QUESTION OF THE EMERGENCY
REGULATION. NOTABLY IN
SITUATIONS WHERE WORKERS HEALTH
IS BEING YEAH YOU KNOW JUST
THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED
IMMEDIATELY A WILDFIRE SMOKING
WITH CO THAT. THE BOARD I THINK
IT NOTED BUT SENATOR AND MR
STEIGER CAN SKIP ST PROCESSES
VIA AN EMERGENCY REGULATION
THAT CAN BE DONE. FOR TALKING
ABOUT HERE IS FOR THE DAY TO
DAY BUSINESS WITH THE MAIN.
REGULATIONS THAT YOU'RE NOT
RUSHED. DO WE GET THE ACT L.
AND I THINK THAT THE SOME WHERE
WELL IT'S PROPERTY GIVEN
EMERGENCY SETTING. NOT PROPERTY
DUE TO THE MAINSTAY OF THE
WORK- ONE OTHER POINT WHICH
THEN CORRECT NOW CLOSED AND
APPRECIATE THE TIME- THERE WAS
A COMMENT THAT HELLO TO ALREADY
DOES THOROUGH ECONOMIC ANALYSIS
WHICH IS OUT THERE. I HAVEN'T
WORKED IN CALIFORNIA FOR
CALCHAMBER. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
ECONOMIC OUT THERE IS BEING
BIRD TO THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
PROCESS IT'S NOT ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS THE TAX IS NOT
FINALIZED YOU HAVE VERY LITTLE
TIME TO REVIEW IT- A MONTH
UNLESS IT'S NOT TIME TO DO
ECONOMIC IN OUT THAT FIRST
STATEWIDE. REGULATION THAT
CHANGES THINGS. SO THAT IS NOT
COMPARABLE TO SYRIA NOR AT THE
EXAMPLE IF YOU SEE ANYTHING
BEING DONE I WENT TO YOU SEE A
THING. IT'S A VERY SMALL SCHOOL
TO PAY THAT YOU THE EIGHTH IN
THE BAM FROM THIS PROCESS AND
THAT WE SHOULD BAN ALL CALLOW
TO WRECK THE IT'S JUST AN
INCOMPARABLE ANALOGY- BUT- I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS OF
COURSE WITH SPEED AND I DO WISH
THAT THE ANARCHY REGULATION HAD
MOVED MORE QUICKLY- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. UP TO
CAN YOU PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
THOSE OPPOSE. YEAH ERICA MISTER
CHAIRMAN RICH CHRISTMAS CEILIDH
ON BEHALF OF THE HOLLYWOOD
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU- NO ONE
ELSE IN THE ROOMS ARE GONE-
MODERATOR WE HAVE FOLKS IN
OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE TO US
BEFORE TENTH. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
S. B. FOUR CHAN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THE END ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
SIRI IN Q. OR SHOWING FORTY
NINE SHE'S GLAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STATE FORGET
ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED IN THE LINER COMMENTS
THAT THOSE THAT MR MAITRI.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS RATTLING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
LORD DAY NOVEMBER CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES THE TECHNOLOGY SO
SHAKEN WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE ONE
MORE IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THE RIGHT NUMBER.
THANKS FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
WHAT WILL BE ABOUT TO COMMITTEE
FOR THE COMMENTS FROM MOTIONS.
OKAY TO MOTIONS AND ORDERS
AUTHORIZED OWNER JONES SAWYER
IN THE COMMENTS. BUT THANK YOU-
CENTER LABEL FOR BRING THIS
IMPORTANT WORKER SAFETY BILL
FORWARD JUDGE CLOSED THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT- THE LONG
DIATRIBE BY THE- CALCHAMBER
WE'RE JUST AND FUNDAMENTAL
DISAGREEMENT WITH THEM. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH HI
MADAM SECRETARY OF WILL CALL ON
AS BEFORE TEN PLEASE. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I AGENTS WORK
OR JONES WERE IRATE. HI REYES
EYES ZERO. FORT THE BILL AT THE
BILLS UP THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU
MISTER THANK YOU MEMBERS POSTED
ON THE ITEM THREE SB FIVE FORTY
NINE. SENATORS JONES. LEAVE A
MESSAGE FOR PEOPLE. SB FIVE
FORTY NINE- DOES ENJOY A DO
PASS HUMAN SERVICES
RECOMMENDATION I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S ANY FORMAL OPPOSITION-
CENTER JUDGMENT AGAIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. MOTION A SECOND
THANK YOU. WELL THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT SB FIVE
FORTY NINE REQUIRES SOCIAL
WORKERS WHO WERE DECLARED
ESSENTIAL WORKERS SHOULD
RECEIVE THE SAME ACCESS TO
HEALTH AND SAFETY EQUIPMENT AS
OTHER CENTRAL WORKERS I'M HAPPY
TO GO THROUGH SOME MORE
EXPLANATION IF YOU WISH OR I
WOULD DIE CLOSE WITH IT ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I DO BELIEVE YOU HAVE ONE
WITNESS I BELIEVE YES SOME WILL
GO AHEAD AND GO TO EUROPE OF
THE DEFERRED TO THE WITNESS
YEAH ABSOLUTELYWE'RE GOING TO
GO TO YOUR WITNESS OF THE BODY
SANCHEZ OF YOUR ON THE PHONE
YOU MAY BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. COMMEMORATED WE KNOW IF
WE HAVE. OR WHAT IS ON THE
PHONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU
MAY HAVE YOUR CELL PHONE YOU.
APOLOGIES THE ONLY BE FANTASTIC
ON BEHALF OF THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA. GET READY FOR MY
TESTIMONY YES SORRY PLEASE-
APOLOGIES GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF HEAVY PHANTASM THE
UP ABOUT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING CHILD WELFARE
SOCIAL WORKERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR SB
FIVE FORTY NINE PER CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES SOCIAL WORKER
TASKED WITH THE CARE AND
WELFARE OF ABUSED AND NEGLECTED
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES SYSTEMS
AND THE INVESTIGATION OF
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF ABUSE
AND NEGLECT ALLEGATIONS EVERY
YEAR THE PANDEMIC COULD AMPLIFY
THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR WORK FOR
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION UNFORTUNATELY ALSO
AMPLIFIED THE GAP BETWEEN THE
INTEGRAL ROLE WE PLAY AS A
CENTRAL WORKERS AND THE VALUE
THAT ROLE IS SOMETIMES GIVEN
WHEN DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE WE
FALL IN THE ESSENTIAL WORK A
PRIORITY LIST OR IF. EVEN ON
THAT LIST AT ALL ARE MADE
DURING THE PANDEMIC MY SOCIAL
WORKERS WERE NOT GIVEN PRIORITY
FOR PP DISTRIBUTION ALTHOUGH
THEY CONTINUED THROUGH OUT THE
PANDEMIC TAB IN PERSON VISITS
WITH CHILDREN YOUTH AND
FAMILIES OFTEN TRANSPORTING
CHILDREN AND YOUTH OF THEIR
VEHICLES WHEN FORCED TO REMOVE
THEM FROM HOME. THEY WERE NOT
PROVIDED SANITIZING MATERIALS
THEY WERE FORCED AT TIMES TO
SHARE MATH PUTTING THEMSELVES
THEIR FAMILIES AND THE CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES THEY SERVE
IN HARM'S WAY WHEN THE VACCINE
ROLLOUT BEGAN THEY WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE PRIORITY
DISTRIBUTIONS HERE UNTIL MID
MARCH ALL OCCURRED WHILE THEY
WERE DEEMED FROM DAY ONE AT THE
FEDERAL WORKERS. THEY ARE
ESSENTIAL AND THE WORK THEY DO
IS ESSENTIAL FOR THE ABUSED AND
NEGLECTED CHILDREN AND YOUTH
THEY ARE TASKED WITH PROTECTING
THE LAW CURRENTLY DOES NOT
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE PROTECTED
AS WELL SB FIVE FORTY NINE
NEARLY ENSURES THAT THEY ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSES OF
PRIORITY DISTRIBUTION SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO DO THA
ESSENTIAL AND IMPORTANT WORK
SAFELY. THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THE YOU VERY
MUCH. BUT WE HAVE ANYONE. IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. WILL MOVE
ON- MODERATOR MADAM READ WE
HAVE ANYONE SOME ON THE PHONE
SB. FIVE FORTY NINE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN UPPORT
ADVANCED BE FIVE FORTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ONE
LINE IN Q. LINE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF SB FIVE
FOUR NINE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES HOWEVER IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE ROOM TO LIKE
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. NOT SEEING
ANYONE WE CAN GO AHEAD OF THE
PHONE LINES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
FORTY NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FIVE FORTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ SECOND
BY SOME MEMBER RAMOS. NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU
SENATOR JOHN FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD ON BEHALF. OF OUR
WONDERFUL SOCIAL WORKERS AND
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU SIR AS
PLATE LAST FOR I HAVE A- THANK
YOU. A MAN SECRETARY FROM WILL
CALL THE ROLL ON SB FIVE FORTY
NINE PLEASE. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
FLOOR GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
DON'T SWEAR JONES SAWYER I
VEGAS. REYES I ZERO WARD THE
FACT THAT THOSE OUT THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATOR NICHOLAS
FISHING THE SPORT THANK YOU.
AND IS AWAITING THE NEXT
AUTHOR- I THINK EVERYONE'S BEEN
HERE EXCEPT FOR ASSIGNED AREAS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO- HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD ON. HERE.
FOR THE REST OF. YEAH BECAUSE I
THINK SHOWS YOU MANAGED A
COUPLE WAS GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY OUT ON SO YOU WANT
TO STICK AROUND LATER. C. SB
SIXTY TWO RARE FIVE RADIUS I.
SHE FUND. FOR TEN- GREAT GREAT
THANK YOU THE VICTIM ONE ALSO
CAUGHT UP AND I BELIEVE WE'RE
CALLING FOR OTHERS TO SHOW UP.
I CAN TAKE PICTURES. OF THE-
THANKS. FOR TO. OKAY OTHER
OTHER SELFIE. MORE LIKE. YEAH
WELL THAT'S UHHUH UHHUH SURE
SURE. A I LIKE I LIKE THE
MASCARA YEAH. WITH YOUR SKILLS.
THE PROBLEM. FOR OVER TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS SO FAR BURKE
FOR A LOT OF- THE CUSTOMER
CAN'T. BUT A LOT OF. I WOULD. I
WANT TO TALK TO SOMEBODY ABOUT
BRIDGING. THOSE ARE THE BEST.
YEAH YEAH. BUT IF YEAH ANYONE
WE HAVE. REGARDING EMAIL
POLITICIANS AND- FOR GO THE
ONLY LIKE WOMEN WHO ARE
ACTIVELY GETTING NOT WITH THE
PACKAGE THAT THAT MAN WHO GAVE
THEM IS THAT WEIRD IT WAS LIKE
FROM. SO I HAVE ALREADY WHAT WE
POSE LIKE ABOUT THEMSELVES
NUCLEAR. CARRYING SOME. LIKE
THAT IF I HAVE BEEN WITH ARE
DOING ACTIVELY THINGS
INTERESTING. NOT HANG IN THERE.
READ A LOT OF I DON'T IT HAS A
LONG BEFORE ONE. YEAH NEVER DO
ANYTHING TO GET CREDIT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO ANYTHING. I'M
JOKING I JUST CRIED OUT. YEAH
MAKING WORDS BECAUSE I THOUGHT
HE FOR THE BILL FOR A LOT WAS
JUST THERE LOT OF WHAT WITH-
FIVE MONTHS YEAH. ALL RIGHT I
THINK YOU DON'T HAVE LABOR.
YEAH. THE ADELINE. PLEASE
HERTZBERG HASN'T OFFICIALLY.
YOU KNOW BACK UP MISTER VIRUS
ON. CONSISTING YEAH. ONE PERSON
I DON'T. I FELT LIKE THE
REQUIRED FEEDBACK IN FIVE
MINUTES. REMEMBER THE DALLAS
WILL PRESENT. I'M HERE. YEAH
ALL RIGHT I DON'T WANT FOR THE
CHECK. YES SENATE MCGUIRE SB
SIX EIGHTY FIVE ITEM PHOTO
WHATEVER ITEM THIS MAY BEGIN TO
READ. THANK YOU SO MUCH WILL
WANT TO SEE GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU AS WELL RESEARCHER ALONG
WITH YOUR STAFF- FOR YOUR AS
SINCERE ENGAGEMENT IN THE BILL
AND GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M NEARLY A
QUARTER OF ALL CALIFORNIA PAYER
SO SHIPPED TO THE FRESH MARKET
COME FROM BEAUTIFUL COUNTY OF
LAKE AT THAT'S LOCATED IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA NOW FOR
GENERATIONS IT'S BEEN A BIT OF
A UNIQUE SITUATION IN LAKE
COUNTY. RESIDENTS HAVE WORKED A
PAIR HARVEST TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE SWEET AND JUICY
DELICACIES CAN BE DELIVERED TO
STORE SHELVES AROUND AMERICA
AND THROUGHOUT THE WORLD NOW
IT'S A BIT OF A UNIQUE
SITUATION IN LAKE COUNTY- BE
PACKING SEASON IS EXTREMELY
SHORT. AND IT. LASTS ONLY FOUR
TO SEVEN WEEKS. AND IT HAVE AR
AUG OF A YEAR- SO AT ITS PEAK
AT IT COMPETES WITH OTHER TOP
INDUSTRIES WITHIN. THE COUNTY
WHICH IS TOURISM I IN
PARTICULAR SO THAT MEANS LABOR
IS EXTREMELY SHORT IN DUE TO
THOSE LABOR SHORTAGES. SB SIX
THIRTY FIVE EXTENSIVE STATE LAW
THAT ALLOWS SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS TO BE TO
WORK OVERTIME WITH PACKING
PEARS IN AUGUST. WHEN SCHOOL IS
NOT IN SESSION. TO ALLEVIATE
THE SUMMER JOBS SHORTAGE. NOW
ALL WORK PERMITS UNDER THIS
PROGRAM. THEY ARE SUPERVISED
AND MANAGED THROUGH THE LAKE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION- AND
<c.red>T'S DIRECTLY SUPERVISED BY THE</c>
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS WHO WILL BE WITH US
HERE TODAY. AND MISTER
FALKENBERG SUPPORTS THE
PROGRAM. AT THE PROGRAM IS THEN
OVERSEEN AT THE SECOND LAYER-
ON A STATEWIDE LEVEL BY THE
OFFICE OF THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER. NOW THE RECENT
REPORTS THAT CAME FROM- THE
LAST FIVE YEARS AND WE ARE IN
FRONT OF YOUR COMMITTEE- IT
SHOWS THAT THERE ARE BEEN
ABSOLUTELY ZERO VIOLATIONS.
ZERO VIOLATIONS- WITH THE LAKE
COUNTY PROGRAM SINCE THE LAST
TIME WE WERE IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THAT THESE PERMITS
CANNOT BE ISSUED THEY CAN'T BE
ISSUED DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR
WHICH MEANS STUDENTS CANNOT
WORK WHEN SCHOOL IS IN SESSION.
ONLY DURING THOSE AT STRICT SIX
TO SEVEN WEEKS DURING HARVEST.
NOW THIS ORIGINAL BILL PASSED
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX EVERY
EXTENSION SINCE HAS RECEIVED
BROAD SUPPORT. ON A BIPARTISAN
BASIS NOW THIS WOULD EXTEND THE
SUNSET FROM JANUARY TWENTY TWO-
EXCUSE ME UNTIL JANUARY TWENTY
THIRTY TWO. IT WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE AS IT DID LAST TIME
THAT THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
FILED A NEW REPORT BY TWENTY
THIRTY. THAT'S THE REPORT THAT
WAS JUST REFERENCING- AND THEN
ALSO MAINTAIN ALL THIS THE
STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS FOR
EMPLOYERS WHO USED TO LIVE. IN
MISTER CHAIR INTO THE COMMITTEE
I HAVE TO DATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF LAKE COUNTY SCHOOLS. BROCK
FALKENBERG WITH US IS A
WELLESLEY BROWN UP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FRESH ASSOCIATION
CHAIR THANK YOU CAN FOR BE
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND SO.
FOR FALKENBERG LOUIS BROWN-
WHERE IS READY TO GO- MISTER
FALKENBERG IF YOU'RE THERE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD AND TO MAKE UP TO
TWO MINUTES EACH PLEASE.
CRESCENTA AND GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS BROCK HOLCOMB BURKE
LAKE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
SCHOOLS. I'M SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT. OF SB SIX EIGHTY FIVE.
FIFTY WILL EXTEND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MINORS AGES
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN. TO GAIN
MEANINGFUL TEMPORARY SUMMER
TIME EMPLOYMENT. BY SUMMERTIME
I WOULD MEAN. SCHOOL IS NOT IN
SESSION NOT THAT IT'S A
CALENDAR DECEMBER TIME BUT THE
SCHOOL IS NOT IN SESSION. THEY
COUNTY OF TRADITION SUFFERED
THE CON THAT LACK BEHIND THE
REST OF CALIFORNIA AS A RESULT
IT IS SOMETIMES NECESSARY FOR
TEENS TO WORK. IN ORDER TO HAVE
SPENDING MONEY FOR SCHOOL
SUPPLIES AND CLOTHING. THIS
BILL SIMPLY EXTENDS IN NARAL
LAW THAT HAVE BEEN IN PLACE FOR
MANY YEARS ALLOWING LAKE COUNTY
MINERS TO CONTINUE AN
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY. THAT
THEY HAVE HISTORICALLY
BENEFITED FROM. AS NOTED IN THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL. ACTIS
REQUIRED THE ANNUAL APPROVAL OF
THE LAKE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION HEALTHY WE STAFF
MEETING WITH PACKING SHED
MANAGERS TO REVIEW PRACTICES
PROCEDURES AND EXPECTATIONS
PRIOR TO GRANTING THAT ANNUAL
APPROVAL. ADDITIONALLY THE
COUNTY OFFICE OVERSEES ALL WORK
PERMITS FOR THE MINORS INVOLVED
IN THIS PROGRAM. OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN IS THAT THE HEALTH
SAFETY AND WELFARE OF THE
MINERS IS A DRASTIC. PROGRAM
BENEFITS THE YOUTH INVOLVED SB
SIXTY FIVE WILL PROVIDE LASTING
BENEFITS TO THE TEAMS AND
WORKING FAMILIES OF LAKE COUNTY
SUCH AS FOSTERING LIFELONG
LEARNING. DEVELOPING A STRONG
WORK ETHIC AND STRESS IN THE
COMPLETION OF THEIR EDUCATION.
MOST IMPORTANTLY IT ADDRESSES
THE SAFETY AND WELFARE OF THE
MINORS INVOLVED I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON IT SB
SIX EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I'M NEXT WILL HAVE LOUIS
BROWN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
BILLY BROWN CALLING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FRESH
FRUIT ASSOCIATION AND
SPECIFICALLY ON BEHALF OF OUR
PACKING SHED MANAGERS AND
COMPANIES LOCATED IN LAKE
COUNTY HI THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
TRADITION IN LAKE COUNTY- THAT
HAS BEEN A STRONG PARTNERSHIP-
WITH THE PAIR INDUSTRY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION- WE
TAKE THAT RESPONSIBILITY
SERIOUSLY. AND WE ARE HERE TO
ASK ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT THE
PROGRAM AND ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ANYONE IN THE ROOM
IN SUPPORT IF NOT WE'LL GO HEAD
TO THE PHONE FOR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF THE PHONE. Q. AND
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. SIX EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE MINING Q.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT MY NUMBER. WINDS FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CAREY MEMBERS ANTHONY MILLION
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PEAR GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
HOWEVER THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
WITNESSES OPPOSITION IS OR
ANYONE. IN THE ROOM. NO ONE IN
THE ROOM ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION. SB SIX THIRTY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IF YOU
WERE IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RED. I'M
I'M SORRY SENATOR AND YOU KNOW
THAT I FIVE YEARS AGO I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS WELL I THINK IT'S
QUITE HONESTLY SHAMEFUL THAT
ORGANIZED LABOR IS NOT- JUST ON
PRINCIPLE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL. BECAUSE DESPITE WHAT. WAS
SAID IN THE PRESENTATION I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR WITHOUT THIS
BILL SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLDS COULD STILL WORK FORTY
HOURS A WEEK. EIGHT FIVE SIX.
EIGHT HOUR DAYS AND TO SUGGEST
THAT THIS TEACHES KIDS WORK
ETHIC BECAUSE WE ARE- ALLOWING
THEM TO WORK SIXTY HOURS IN A
WEEK IS- DISTURBING TO ME
PERSONALLY IT I UNDERSTAND THIS
IS A UNIQUE SITUATION I'VE
TALKED TO MULTIPLE PEOPLE ABOUT
THE PAIR SEASON HOW SHORT IT
IS. WHAT HAPPENS TO JUST FIT
INTO THE SUMMER MONTHS- AND HOW
THIS PROGRAM IS UNIQUE AND PART
OF THE TRADITION OF LAKE COUNTY
WHERE THEY CAN'T FIND
EMPLOYMENT. BUT I THINK FOR ME
PERSONALLY- I THINK THAT THE
ONLY WAY WE- HONOR. OUR OUR
CHILD LABOR LAWS IN THE WHICH
WERE HARD FOUGHT- PEOPLE
LITERALLY DIED FOR THEM IS WE
DON'T ALLOW THESE KINDS OF
EXCEPTIONS AND SO- I HAVE TO
VOTE NO I WILL CONTINUE VOTE NO
I'M I'M- IT'S IN NO WAY
PERSONAL. I WOULD I WOULD
SUGGEST THOUGH THAT MAYBE WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT IT WE CAN TALK
ABOUT WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
LAKE COUNTY AND THE NEED BUT TO
SUGGEST. THAT CHILDREN NEED TO
WORK SIXTY HOURS A WEEK TO
TEACH THEM WORK ETHIC OR TO
GIVE THEM SOME OPPORTUNITY. I'M
NOT EVEN SURE IF I CAN FOLLOW
THAT THROUGH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
FILL EDUCATIONAL NEEDS IN OTHER
WORDS ARE YOU SAYING SO THAT
THEY DON'T END UP IN A PACKING
HOUSE I MEAN. IT'S A I I'M NOT
I DON'T EVEN UNDERSTAND THAT
ARGUMENT AT LEAST LET'S BE
HONEST IT IS S. AS AN
EMPLOYMENT NEED FOR LAKE COUNTY
FOR THE- ACTORS BUT- I DON'T.
PERSONALLY THINK THERE'S ANY-
REASON. WHY WE SHOULD BE
AWARDING ANYONE. AN EXEMPTION
WHEN IT COMES TO CHILD LABOR
LAWS AND I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR UNDER CURRENT LAW FORTY
EIGHT HOURS THEY COULD WORK
THEY WOULDN'T NEED THIS
EXEMPTION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SIXTY HOUR WEEKS DURING THE
SUMMERTIME FOR KIDS WHO ARE
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD
SO. I'M FOR THAT REASON I HAVE
TO BUT NO CAM I THINK. THANK
YOU A SERVICE. I WAS NOT. PRIVY
TO THE PRIOR- HEARINGS. BUT
LISTENING TO THE SUPERINTENDENT
TALK ABOUT. THIS PROVIDING THE
STUDENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW
STRONG WORK ETHIC TALKING ABOUT
CONTINUING AN IMPORTANT
TRADITION. I WAS A FARM WORKER
MYSELF WITH PICKED ONIONS AND
GRAPES AND TEN HOURS A DAY I
CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE DOING THAT
BUT. TO HELP THE SUPERINTENDENT
TO SAY. THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS GOOD AND I SEE THAT IT
ALSO IN THE ANALYSIS IT SAYS
THAT. THEY WILL TEACH THESE
YOUNG. CHILDREN TO LEARN THE
DESIRE TO DO BETTER TO BETTER
THEMSELVES THROUGH HIGHER
EDUCATION VOCATIONAL TRADES. I
ABSOLUTELY DON'T SEE THE
CONNECTION AND TO SHOW REAL
WORK EXPERIENCE ON A RESUME
FORTY EIGHT HOURS A WEEK WILL
SHOW THAT WORK EXPERIENCE ON A
RESUME. AND A SOURCE FOR
POSITIVE LETTER OF
RECOMMENDATION- RIGHT. IT
SADDENS ME TO HEAR THE
SUPERINTENDENT GIVE HIS HIS
TESTIMONY I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT
THE LEADER OF THE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM WOULD COME BEFORE US AND
SAY THIS IS A GREAT THING.
BECAUSE THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MEXICAN
KIDS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT KIDS
WHO FOR WHATEVER REASON HAVE
BEEN RAISED WORKING IN THE
FIELDS AND I JUST SEE THIS AS-
BASICALLY SAYING THIS IS ALL
YOU CAN GET. AND LET'S GET TO
DOING MORE FOR US. I ABSOLUTELY.
CANNOT AND WOULD NOT SUPPORT
SOMETHING THAT THAT. IT AND I'M
SORRY THAT THE AT AT THE AUG
THIS IS ACTUALLY NOTHING-
PERSONAL SENATOR- I APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU DO BUT-
THIS IS JUST LISTENING TO THIS
WAS VERY DIFFICULT QUITE
FRANKLY. READING THE ANALYSIS
IS DIFFICULT BUT LISTENING TO
THE SUPERINTENDENT. SUPPORT AND%
ENDORSE AND TRY TO SHOW WAS THE
GREATNESS OF. SUCH A SUCH A BIG
THE EXEMPTION ALLOWING THESE
CHILDREN TO WORK. TEN HOURS A
DAY IN UP TO SIXTY HOURS A WEEK.
I IT IS HARD FOR ME TO ACCEPT-
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR WORK.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY REQUIRE I
JUST HAVE TWO QUESTIONS FOR
THIS- MAYBE IN THE EXPERIENCE
OF THIS PROGRAM NO THIS HAS
BEEN AN EXISTING EXEMPTION FOR
SOME TIME- ARE THE- YOUTH WHO
ARE SIX YEARS SEVEN YEARS OLD-
AND AVAILING THEMSELVES OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY- ARE THE REQUIRED
TO BE WORKING UP TO THE SIXTY
HOURS ON THE CONDITION OF
EMPLOYMENT SO ARE THEIR
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE EXERCISING
THIS EXEMPTION- WHO ARE SAYING
THAT IF THEY WANT TO WORK AT-
WHAT COMPANY ACCENT FARM. AND
FARM TAX- THAT THEY MUST WORK
FIFTY FIVE HOURS A WEEK OR IF
THE JOB WOULD NOT BE AVAILABLE
TO THEM AT ALL YEAH WE TALKED
OKAY- IT WOULD BE ABLE TO BRING
A LITTLE MORE COMFORT IF THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS- ALSO-
CLARIFIED MAYBE IN THIS
LEGISLATION THAT- A CONDITION
OF EMPLOYMENT YOU KNOW SHALL
NOT REQUIRE- AN INDIVIDUAL TO
WORK MORE THAN FORTY EIGHT
HOURS A WEEK- AND SECONDLY I
JUST WANT ALSO FOR
CLARIFICATION OR THE RECEIVING
TIME AND A HALF- FOR HOURS
WORKED MORE THAN FORTY HOURS A
WEEK. SENATE BRINGING AND YOU
TO GET BACK ITS OVER TO BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S OVER DOUBLE
OVERTIME OKAY YEAH OVERTIME
LAWS ARE OKAY. I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S TIME AND A HALF I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE ACTUAL RATE IS IT
BUT SELL OKAY IT IS OVERTIME.
OKAY COULD I WON JUST ONE EXTRA
THAT THAT THAT WOULD BE MISSED
HERE TO THROUGH THIS SITE
EXEMPTION. OF COURSE THAT'S
PART OF HIS LAN AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW NOT.
NOT WITHSTANDING MAYBE SOME OF
THE TESTIMONY WHICH I AM I AM
IS TAKING ANOTHER CALL IN AND
OUT HERE AND MISS THAT. THAT
WHICH WOULD BRING ME CONCERN AS
WELL- I DO SEE THIS AS- YOU
KNOW AND IT'S OPPORTUNITY FOR
SPECIFIC COUNTY FOR SPECIFIC-
INDUSTRY HERE I'M I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS GOING FORWARD AND
IF YOU COULD- POSSIBLY WORK ON-
YOU KNOW SOME OF THOSE
CLARIFICATIONS AT A FUTURE.
TIME POINT IN THE ASSEMBLY I
THINK THAT WOULD BRING SOME
COMFORT. ABSOLUTELY SIR- SO
LOOK I APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMENTS AND CLARIFICATIONS-
WE'D BE MORE THAN WILLING TO BE
ABLE TO. COMMIT TO AMENDED IF
THIS BILL WERE TO MOVE FURTHER
TODAY. CLARIFIED THAT IT WOULD
BE VOLUNTARY BECAUSE THAT'S THE
INTENT BY THE WAY SO HAPPY TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT- NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO- SEPTEMBER GONZALEZ
IS ABSOLUTELY REYES ACTUALLY
RIGHT. AT THIS IS A VERY
SPECIFIC. FOCUS BASED OFF OF
LABOR SHORTAGES. AND I. WANT TO
ASSURE YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS SIMPLY ABOUT- AND IT'S
OPTIONAL TO BE ABLE TO WORK
THAT- ADDITIONAL THOSE
ADDITIONAL HOURS- AND
UNDERSTAND WHERE- THIS GONZALEZ
AS WELL AS MAJORITY LEADER.
HAVE JUST MENTIONED- IN REGARDS
TO THE WORDS THAT WERE USING
WORDS MATTER COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THAT- AND ONE OF THE
ITEMS THAT I USE SURE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU IS THAT. HI
THIS IS SOMETHINGTHAT WILL
WORK WITH EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU ON- IF THIS BILL WERE TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD-
BECAUSE IT REALLY IS. SIGNATURE
ISSUE FOR SPECIFIC. PROJECTS
TO. AVOID BEYOND. CUT WITH THE
REQUIRED REPORT WAS REQUIRED
FOR YEARS AGO. I THERE HAVE
BEEN AFTER ZERO OUT BY IT IS SO
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS UNDERSTAND THAT AS WELL.
THANK YOU SENATOR ABOUT THAT
REPORT THERE ARE JUST A COUPLE
THINGS THAT THAT ARE CONCERNING
TO ME- ONE THIS KEEPS ME IN
PATCHES A LAKE COUNTY PROGRAM
BUT IN FACT THAT REPORT. STATES
SOMEHOW THAT IT WAS ALSO USED
IN FRESNO COUNTY SO. HEY I SAW
THAT AS WELL AND THERE WAS A
VIOLATION FRESNO COUNTY AND
I'LL BE HONEST TO YOU- SOME
NUMBER I DON'T KNOW CITIES
MENTIONED IS NOT JUST FOR LIKE
COUNTY IF THEY'RE BEING GRANTED
IN FRESNO COUNTY AS WELL. THIS
BILL IS JUST REALLY COUNTY. SO
WE DON'T KNOW WHY AND FRESNO
COUNTY WELL I IF I WERE. I
DON'T AN ATTORNEY I MIGHT LOOK
INTO YOU KNOW THE VIOLATION
CHILD LABOR LAWS AND IN FRESNO
COUNTY- I ASSURE YOU THIS BILL
BEFORE YOU IS SIMPLY FOCUS ON
MY COUNTY SO THE REPORT-
CLEARLY STATE SO THAT THIS WAS
ALSO HAPPENING FRESNO COUNTY.
SO WE KNOW THERE WAS AN
INCIDENT IN FRESNO COUNTY AND
THE SOME MEMBERS HAVE TO THE
CREE OTHER THING THAT BOTHERS
ME ON THE REPORT IS THAT. THE
INSPECTION IF YOU WILL OR THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE FOR
TWENTY TWENTY WAS DONE BY A
PHONE INTERVIEW WITH THE
MANAGER. AND SO GIVEN WHAT WE
SAW IN A LOT OF PACKING HOUSES
AND DIFFERENT THINGS DURING THE
PANDEMIC- I THINK IT'S-
DISGRACEFUL THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER- SIMPLY CALLED
MANAGERS AND ASKED WITH
EVERYTHING OKAY IN TWENTY
TWENTY. TO PROVIDE US WITH A
REPORT TODAY THAT WE'RE BASING.
NOW NOT ANOTHER FIVE YEARS BUT
TEN YEARS ON- I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT THAT'S NOT QUITE AN
INSPECTION IT'S NOT CLEAR AN
INSPECTION WAS EVER DONE WHEN
THERE WERE WORKERS THERE- AND
SO IF WE'RE RELYING SIMPLY ON-
DATA FROM THE EMPLOYER. AT NO.
I AM NOT SUGGESTING THESE MAY
BE REALLY I REALLY I HATE TO DO
THIS BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW THESE
EMPLOYERS I'M NOT SUGGESTING
ANYTHING WE HAVE NO REASON. TO
SUGGEST OTHERWISE BUT- GIVEN-
HOW WE USUALLY DO REPORTS
PERHAPS PERHAPS THIS IS MORE OF
A- AND I THINK ACTUALLY I COULD
BE WRONG BUT I MIGHT HAVE
REQUIRED THE REPORT FIVE YEARS
AGO IN APPROPRIATIONS- AND
PERHAPS THE REPORT SHOULD BE
BEING DONE BY OSHA AS WELL AS
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER BECAUSE
LIKE KERN. COMMISSIONER DOESN'T
NORMALLY DO THESE REPORTS ALSO
IF THIS IS SO TIED INTO THE
COUNTY- EDUCATION OFFICE IT BE
INTERESTING OR IT WOULD IT
WOULD BE- THAT WOULD HELP US.
GUIDE THESE TYPES OF EXEMPTIONS
TO NOTE THE STUDENTS- YOU KNOW
DID THE STUDENTS GRADUATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL IS THIS EXEMPTION I
AM OBVIOUSLY THAT. THE
SUPERINTENDENT IN THE COUNTY-
SUPPORTS IN AND PUSHES THIS AT
BUT WHAT WHAT IS THE ACTUAL
OUTCOME OF STUDENTS BECAUSE
IT'S NOT SIMPLY LIKE. WAS THERE
ONE INJURY REPORTED YES WE
ALREADY KNOW THAT THIS GOES ARE
CHILD LABOR LAWS GO WALK BE
BEYOND HEALTH AND SAFETY RIGHT
THERE THERE THE REASON WE HAVE
THEM IS BECAUSE CHILDREN SHOULD
BE CHILDREN. I'M NOT BE IT AND-
NOT BECAUSE THEY WILLINGLY IF
YOU WILL WE ALSO THOSE OF US I
THINK THAT COME FROM THESE
BACKGROUNDS UNDERSTAND MORE
THAT THAT- WILLINGLY IS BECAUSE
YOU MIGHT HAVE TO PAY THEBILLS
NOT A CHILL CHILD WANTS TO
SPEND TEN. HOURS A DAY ALL
SUMMER LONG IN A PACKING HOUSE-
SO I JUST I THINK DOES THIS GO
TO APPROPRIATE I BELIEVE THIS
DOES GET ABOUT APPROPRIATIONS
SO MAYBE WE CAN TALK THROUGH
SOME OF THAT IN THERE BUT I
WANT YOU TO AT LEAST KNOW HOW
I'M THINKING AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION IN PUBLIC. THIS IS
WHY I DON'T BELIEVE IN AND-
WEAKENING OUR CHILD LABOR LAWS
BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE TO KNOW IS
SO EXTENSIVE TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH SOMETHING LIKE
THIS BUT THAT NOW AND NOW IT'S
BECOMING YOU KNOW IT'S HARD TO
JUSTIFY. THAT'S ON. IF YOU LOOK
AT YES SIR A 100% IN IN THE-
BUT I'VE APPRECIATED I'M NOT
THE SAME IT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE IN
THE ROOM HERE TWO DAYS THAT YOU
HAVE ALWAYS ENGAGE SINCERELY.
AND ON THIS ISSUE- AND ON THE
ISSUE OF- O. T. NOT REQUIRED-
LABOR COMMISSIONER REPORT- AND
SOME ADDITIONAL STATISTICS THAT
YOU'VE JUST MENTIONED. WOULD BE
MORE THAN WILLING AND WOULD
WELCOME. FURTHER ENGAGEMENT AND
CONVERSATION SINCERELY ON- WHAT
SOME OF THOSE DATA POINTS COULD
BE. I'M AN THANK YOU AS A
SENATOR I THINK THAT. IN SOME
IN PERSON. ASPECT OF THE REPORT
NOT JUST ONE AND THEN. I WOULD
SUGGEST IF IT'S BEING TOUTED AS
SOMETHING. FROM THE
SUPERINTENDENT ADDED THEN
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES I THINK
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE IMPORTANT AS WELL. I GOT
AROUND OUT ON BUT I KNOW THAT
THE SUMMER THEY ARE NO ONE TO
MAKE A COMMENT AND SO I'LL BE
BACK AS SOON AS I CAN. YES SIR.
CAME IN LATE I HOPE I DIDN'T
MISS. MISS TOO MUCH ON THIS. SO
YOU KNOW THE STUDENTS THEY'RE
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD.
ARE THEY LIVE IN AN AREA THAT
PROBABLY THIS IS. THE
PREDOMINANT. WAGE EARNING. JOBS
THAT THEY CAN GET- AND IT'S
ALSO SOMETHING THAT ENABLES
THEM. IF THIS BILL WERE TO
PASS. ENABLES THEM TO WORK RAGE
SPELLS MUCH AS THEY WANT- TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE ENOUGH MONEY. SO
THAT HOPEFULLY WHEN THEY DO GO
TO SCHOOL IF THEY DO GRADUATE
AND THEY DO GO TO SCHOOL
ALTHOUGH ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
MONEY. TO DO THAT WITH- THERE
ARE TIMES IN. IN IN OUR LIVES.
WHEN WE TURN THE SWITCH ON. AND
THAT MEANS WE MAKE AS MUCH
MONEY AS WE CAN. BECAUSE WE
HAVE BILLS TO PAY OR WE HAVE.
WE HAVE A LIFE TO TRY TO SET
UP. AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THIS IS THIS IS. ALLOWING THAT
NOT FORCING THEM TO DO THAT. I
CORRECT SO I MEAN IS THAT. THE
PROGRAM IS OPTIONAL RIGHT. AND
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS
ARE AT THE AGE WHERE THEY WERE.
IN THERE YOU'RE STARTING TO
HAVE TO MAKE THOSE CHOICES.
THAT THE ADULTS MAKE AND-
DINNER SO. AT I DO YOU KNOW I
DON'T LIKE TO WEAKEN. OUR CHILD
LABOR LAWS THEY THEY'RE THERE
FOR YOU THE EXIST FOR A REASON-
BUT A LOT OF THOSE ARE EXISTING
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE PUT INTO
POSITIONS OF ALMOST. SLAVE
LABOR. AND I DON'T SEE THIS IS
TRYING TO AND YOU KNOW. GO INTO
THAT I SEE IT IS TRYING TO-
ENABLE THEM TO HAVE A WORK
FORCE OUT THERE. NOT HAVE THESE
KIDS HAVE TO TRAVEL OUT OF THE
AREA TO WORK- AND ALSO TO BE
ABLE TO WORK AS MUCH IS THEY
THEY FEEL LIKE WORKING. AND BE
ABLE TO MAKE SOME MONEY FOR THE
FUTURE AND YOU KNOW TRY TO MAKE
MAKE THEIR LIVES. YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY WANT TO BE. SO I'M NOT AS
OPPOSED TO. K. DOING THAT. THE
BASED ON OTHER COMMENTS. THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY ANY
OTHER MEMBERS. YES AND AFTER
LISTENING TO THE DEBATE AND YOU
AND I'VE WORKED. SEVERAL BILLS-
BOTH AGREED AND DISAGREED AND I
KNOW IN YOUR HEART. YOU'RE NOT
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING THAT
WOULD IMPACT OR HURT ANYONE.
WORDS DO MATTER AND I THINK YOU
NEED TO REALLY WORK WITH. THE
E. THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER- TO
REALLY GET THIS TO A PLACE
WHERE. WHERE WHERE PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE- I DON'T HAVE PROBLEMS I
MEAN BUT THE STATEMENT THAT
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
LABOR- IS TROUBLING AND I DON'T
THINK YOU MEANT IT THAT WAY
THAT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MAYBE WE NEED TO. TO
CHANGE LAWS SO THAT WE CAN GET
MORE PEOPLE AND- FOR ME IN
AFTER AMERICAN A CHANGE LAWS TO
STARTS LABOR AND SELL I DON'T
THINK YOU MEANT THAT I DON'T
THINK YOU MEANT THAT IN THAT AS
AS A FUNCTION OF THE ECONOMY WE
NEED TO DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO
GET PEOPLE TO COME TO WORK
DIDN'T WORK SO WELL FOR MY
PEOPLE. AND SO I JUST NEED YOU
TO. KIND OF. WORK THROUGH SOME
OF THE LANGUAGE MAVEN BECAUSE
YOURE FROM AN AREA THAT MAY
NOT. HAVE PEOPLE LIKE. THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SAN DIEGO.
OR FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE THAT
COULD HELP YOU. MASSAGE YOUR
BEST. WORK IT THROUGH SO THAT
WORKS FOR EVERYONE. AND SO I'M
A LAY OFF TODAY I THINK YOU
HAVE ENOUGH TO GET THROUGH. AND
THEN WE GET TO THE FLOOR WHEN
YOU GET THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
I'M HOPING THAT- YOUR SPONSORS.
WE'LL LISTEN TO OTHERS ABOUT
THE LANGUAGE THAT THEY USE
BECAUSE IT CAN IT CAN BE REAL
DISTURBING AND PUT IN IDEAS
THAT YOU YOU DON'T YOU YOU
REALLY DON'T MEAN I'M AND I
KNOW YOU WELL ENOUGH TO KNOW
YOU YOUR INTENT IS GOOD- ED I
WOULD EVEN SUGGEST YOU KNOW
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO WORK- AS OPPOSED
TO WE NEED IT BODIES WE NEED TO
DO WHATEVER WE CAN THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE WEALTH
AND INCOME. TO DISADVANTAGED
VOTE IMMEDIATE AND HOW DO YOU
WORK THROUGH THAT HOW DO YOU
MAKE SURE THAT IT THAT IT MAKES
SENSE WITH THE EXISTING LABOR
LAWS SO. I'M A LAYOFF TODAY AND
HOPEFULLY WHEN YOU GO THROUGH
THE PREPARATIONS IN ALTERNATIVE
FOR WE CANNOT. WE CAN ALL GET
TO. A PLACE THAT WE'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THANK YOU. ALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIMILAR
SAWYER ANYBODY ELSE WITH
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SCENE NINE- I'LL MAKE A MOTION
TO MOVE IT. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU SOMUCH VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE DISCUSSION
BERMAN EACH OF THE SENATE OVER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I LOOK.
JUST BEING VERY HONEST ABOUT
IT- LAKE COUNTY IS A MAJOR
PRIORITY FOR I KNOW THIS STATE
BUT IN PARTICULAR FOR ME. THIS
COMES. JUST A FEW DAYS AFTER
WE'VE LAUNCHED- THE LARGEST AT
CHILDHOOD ANTI POVERTY
INITIATIVE IN THE COUNTY. LAKE
COUNTY IS ONE OF THE POOREST
COUNTIES NOT JUST IN THE STATE
BUT IN THE ENTIRE WEST COAST.
BUT WE HAVE SOME OF THE LOWEST
GRADUATION RATES- ESPECIALLY IN
THE CONDUCT A UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHICH IS. SOUTH PART
OF LAKE COUNTY IN THE CITIES OF
LOWER LAKE IS WELL AS CLEAR
LIKE- AND THEY HAVE YET TO
REBUILD. EVEN 60% OF THE
HOUSING THAT'S BEEN LOST IN THE
VALLEY FIRE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. I SAY ALL THAT IS THIS
IS A MAJOR PRIORITY FOR US AND
IT'S JUST A FEW HOURS OUTSIDE
OF THE WORLD'S TECHNICAL HUB OF
SILICON VALLEY AND IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE- AND I ASSURE YOU
THAT IS JUST AS MUCH FOCUS. ON
AND- WHEN IT COMES TO TACKLING
CHILDHOOD POVERTY INCREASING
GRADUATION RATES AND ENSURING
SUCCESS FOR ALL KIDS OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS- AND WOULD WELCOME
YOU TO- LOOK AT SMART START
BRIGHT FUTURE. WHICH WE JUST
LAUNCHED WITH. THE TO LOCAL
HOSPITALS AT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT UP THERE ALONG WITH
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING. COLLEGE
ACHIEVEMENT NONPROFIT. AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE CAN YOU HAVE MY WORD
AND MANY OF US HAVE WORKED
TOGETHER BEFORE. I THAT WE WILL
WORK TO IMPROVE THE BILL BASED
OFF OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT
FEEDBACK AND I'M REALLY
GRATEFUL. FOR THIS COMPETITION
TODAY. THINKING I DEFINITELY
TAKE IT TO HEART. IF WE'RE
GONNA THE SECOND. THANK YOU
HAVE ABSOLUTELY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA THANK
KALRA HI FLORA FLORA I DID
SALAS GONZALEZ NO JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NOT VOTING RATES.
NO RAISE NO SALE DON'T HI CERDA
I HAVE WORD WORD I THOUGHT TO
MYSELF THANK YOU I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO THANK YOU TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATION ON THE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- LAST PULL
UP AS SB FIVE SEVENTY TWO
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. I START WITH.
THE FIRST PARAGRAPH. THE LABOR
COMMITTEE ISSUE WILL LABOR
ISSUES OFFICE BECAUSE THIS IS
IMPORTANT SAYS. THE MISSION OF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE TO ENSURE
IT JUST STAYS PAY IN EVERY
WORKPLACE IN THE STATE AND TO
PROMOTE ECONOMIC JUSTICE
THROUGH ROBUST ENFORCEMENT OF
LABOR LAWS THE MEASURE BEFORE
YOU IS TO FIX A HOLE IN THE
ROBUST ENFORCEMENT OF LABOR
LAWS. WHAT HAPPENS IN A NUT
SHELL THIRTY SECONDS IS
BASICALLY THIS THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S GOTTA GO APPLY
FOR ABSTRACT FTER THEY'VE GONE
OUT INSIDE CITED SOMEBODY WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS EXPEDITING THAT
BY. THINKING THROUGH IN
FIGURING OUT A WAY TO MAKE IT
WORK BETTER EVERY DAY WE GET UP
AND PART OF THE PURPOSE OF THIS
LEGISLATURES TO FIGURE OUT TO
IMPROVE TO MAKE THINGS BETTER
FROM LEARNED EXPERIENCES THAT'S
THE PURPOSE OF THIS MEASURE.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING I HAVE
A WITNESS BUT- A FROM S. C. I.
U. AND I ALSO HAVE A TECHNIAL
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE BECAUSE OF THIS DAY AND
AGE GOVERNOR'S OFFICES I GUESS
ANYMORE. SINCE THE DAYS I'VE
BEEN AROUND DON'T ACTUALLY IT
THE- INTRODUCED LEGISLATION OR
SUPPORT LEGISLATION THEY JUST
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
BECAUSE THEIR THE OFFICE THAT
ASKED ME TO DO THIS BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE EXPERTS SO WITH
THAT. I'LL TURN IT OVER TO- A
RENEE. BUYER THANK YOU CENTERS
OR NAY BARRETO AS A WITNESS AND
I GUESS WILL BE CAP ON THE ON
FOR TECHNOLOGISTS DOESN'T. THE
SERVER. YES THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG AWFUL TRYING TO THE
THROWBACK I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
WE HAVE SEEN- BILLS LIKE THIS
WORK IN THE PAST FEW YEARS AGO
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE PASSED SB
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT THAT A MAIL
SERVER THREE HUNDRED OF THE LAW
PREVIOUSLY REQUIRED- YOU TO
DELIVER I THINK YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE TO SHARE UP TO THE BANK TO
DELIVER OUT THE NOTICE AND WE
CHANGE THAT COULD BE BY MAIL-
AFTER THAT. I JUST ONE
ORGANIZATION AND NOW THEY TOLD
US THAT THEY WERE COLLECTING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A MONTH
AFTER WORKERS WE THINK THAT
THIS BILL WILL HAVE A SIMILAR
IMPACT WHERE WILL BRING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO THE
POCKETS OF WORKERS AND FOR THAT
REASON I WAS FORCED OUT FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND A- HAVE TO LEON
MAY BE ON THE FOR. A NECKLACE.
TECHNOLOGY SO THE WATER. THIS
DNA OKAY SILVA ON. ANYONE IN
THE ROOM. THE ROOM. ONE ANYONE
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I DO HAVE ONE IN Q. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT MY
NUMBER. ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY
MEMBERS THIS IS DEBBIE GREAT
WELL LET'S SEE IF THE W. WALKER
ST OAKLAND THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU I'M FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER TERA MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANKS MITCH
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
NOW LET'S MOVE ON THE
OPPOSITION THERE ARE NO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
ROOM. SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
PHONE ANYWHERE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE SEVENTY
TWO. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. LAURA WOOD
FOR ABOUT TWENTY WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR COMMENTS NO
COMMENTS. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
ANY CLOSING IT ISN'T JUST
CERTEZA REST MY CASE. EXTRINSIC
ROLE PLEASE ON SB FIVE SEVENTY
TWO SECTION. TRUMP ALSO VOTE IN
A SECOND I'M SORRY. SACRIFICE
OF. WE HAVE WE HAVE EMOTIONS
LIKE ALREADY SO YEAH FORGET.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE KALRA HI
KALRA AYE FLORA FLORA HI
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER. FIVE I HATE REYES FIVE
REYES ICE AT THE- HI I. WARD
WARD ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT WELL
WE'LL RESERVE THE INQUISITION
WILL RESERVE THE INQUISITION
FOR JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
LONGER. YEAH. I COULD DO THAT.
I COULD DO THAT ALL RIGHT SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND VOTE MMHM-
WE'LL START WITH FOR THE
CONSECUTIVE OWNER. CONSENT
CALENDAR THE TWO BILLS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SB SIX FIFTY
SEVEN AND- SB SEVEN SEVEN NINE.
ABSENT MEMBERS- CFO. HI ZERO OO
HI. OKAY SO THAT'S A RESIDENTS
OKAY. LARA I KNOW HE DID HE
WALKED IN MY CAR IS THE YEAH
THIS IS WHAT IT WAS. TO THE
ROAD WAS GOOD THE SIXTY TWO
APPS MEMBERS LARA. HI LAURIE
THIS. YOU YEAH. HELLO LARA
KNOWN FOR. FIVE ZERO NOW. NO SB
FOR TEN- YOUR YOU KNOW FLOOR NO
ZERO HOW ZERO NOW WAR. I SB
FIVE NINE ABSENT FLORA BY FLORA
I ZERO HI ZERO I WARD WARD I.
SB FIVE TO REPEAT. WE ARE CLEAR
SO IT WAS GOOD ALRIGHT THANK
YOU NUMBER IS SEVENTY SEVEN.
YOUR TURN.